this script when I read it was always
compelling story the twists the turns
that the thriller element of it was
always there it certainly gave me a pit
of my stomach maybe as a parent just
reading it I was I had no idea where it
was ending up what was going on I also
was getting a sense of what was deeper
in the DNA of the movie the more
contemplative side of it that made you
think about issues of violence of fear
of control of as I've laid it later
learnt the individual versus the
institutional there was so many themes
but actually it wasn't until Dean evil
nerve came on board that I said yes to
it I had been aware of the script for
about a year but I could see the movie
going in a more generic thriller sort of
version and I could see the movie going
down a track which was something that
would make you think long after the
credits roll and as soon as I saw all
Sondhi which I presume many of you have
seen was nominated for an Oscar that
Denis made I literally was like that and
as soon as I met Tunis that was it for
me and I think Denis I wish he was here
to talk to you as he as he says he loved
many of the themes of the movie but he's
a lover of silence and it's such a rare
thing particularly in a thriller to
actually have time time to get into the
characters the story to the situation I
think that's why it resonates and I
always had a soft spot for that
character as I read it because I got a
sense of a man who had worked really
hard to be the best version of himself
really hard it's a day-to-day battle for
him to protect his family to actually be
a good man and to watch it unravel in
eight or nine days is heartbreaking to
me I'm always sort of very much drawn to
those kind of characters I did a lot of
research as we all did into all those
aspects into the sleep deprivation which
is one of the most fascinating
turns out you should have eight hours
sleep by the way to see you know and
also into the real cases that are going
on right now we see them in the news but
to really watch the
interviews and see them to read what
families have gone through in detail was
harrowing and that gave me a sense of
the responsibility that we all had in
making this film I remember when I had
my son I said this is the worst day and
the best day of my life the best day
because I will never love anyone as much
as I love this kid and the worst day
because I'll never be able to protect
him from all the lessons he has to learn
and everything that he needs to do and
you know my heart goes out to those
families who are experiencing right now
what this movie is about because there
aren't sometimes we forget that we're
doing a movie
it's our playground we get into the
characters it's interesting the
psychology of them as you said there are
four different parents and we all deal
with it in four different ways
right so we have Hughes character that
is you know this is the moral right this
is what I'm doing
we have my character who falls to her
knees in grief and cannot get up we have
viola who is so practical about it in a
certain extent and we have Terrence with
this moral ambiguity and when we asked
people how far would you go
most people say I would be a bit of both
all of those characters somehow and I
think denis villeneuve made a conscious
decision to to do that to help all of us
to think about who we are as human
beings and that's why I think this is
very different than your traditional
Hollywood thriller it brings in those
things and makes us think about our own
humanity I always found it fascinating
as an idea that you would meet this guy
who was written as you know the guy who
was sort of straight-laced and ready to
go and want to solve the case in this
small town but my question was what if
he was a questionmark himself and what
if and what was so fun about making the
movie was that Denis Villeneuve and
Roger Deakins were so fascinated with
deflecting and doing the same thing in
different ways you know you you see the
way something is framed by Roger Deakins
and you know I may be right in front of
the clue directly in front of it the
clues in the centre of the frame and I'm
staring at it while I'm talking to him
on the phone
and yet somehow it doesn't really
register but it does unconsciously and
so to me that's what I thought was
intriguing about the part was to take
something that could be so kind of
filled with cliches and put all these
question marks that everybody would have
to be watching while they were watching
me on try to figure out all the other
question marks so that was basically I
didn't and I I also like the idea of a
detective anybody who's good as a
detective has to be infatuated with the
mind of the criminal as well as
empathize with what you know the
families of this situation or anybody
who's been involved in any kind of crime
is going through so I just I like the
idea of somebody who had had his own
past and had to love that mind of the
criminal and I think that just led me
into a dark interesting world but also a
world to walk in when I was dealing with
them I knew somewhere that I loved that
mind that had done something so horrible
and that at the same time to walk in the
mind of the criminal and to know how
much I love them and how much I wanted
to find those girls I loved the fact
that the movie was more of an allegory
and I almost a litmus test that I think
when people come in to this experience I
think that they probably pick and choose
which character they would be if they
were in that situation and Keller
absolutely the last person who would
think we would be but I don't think we
really know with my character I made a
decided effort that I was not reacting
to the fact that my child was dead only
missing because I could not embrace the
fact that she could be dead and that's
about that's what kept me practical I
think that was more interesting to play
then oh my god she's missing so she's
dead Danny reminded me that the
character is not just connected to his
daughter but he has an intense love for
for the Dover's he has an intense love
of everyone around him he loves music so
I looked at it from the state of a
Buddhist approach towards being and then
total interconnected nature and so I
thought well what if I you know and he
has
such a visceral reaction to all of the
lights when he's coming back and it
makes him sick
so I said well what if he has
synesthesia where one stimulation
affects more than one sense and so in
giving him the sense of synesthesia it
gave him you know there's this
empathetic nature to where he you know
that moral quagmire of what do you do
you know versus the responsibility
versus the your nature and at heart our
nature is to remain you know or at least
Franklin's nature was to remain as a
jewel of creation one of God's children
and maintain his hope but it's hard to
keep hope when everything around you
tells you that there's no hope left and
you're just looking to be reinterment
when I was on a plane he said you have
to remember and every person that you
meet there's a little piece of God in
them and that's who you talk to but you
make sure that they see it in you first
so in trying to keep that little peace
of God and continually see it in Keller
and to continually see it in my wife
that continually see it in myself you
know that is what was the nature of of
my process with the character I was
offered the part before dunya was
attached with another director attached
it didn't really interest me it seemed
like some pretty dark water to swim in
and I do as you all know go fairly
deeply into my characters and that made
me nervous
and then as she was saying I too met
Denis this is a beautiful human being a
very very special man and his filmmaking
that you have the pleasure of watching
it's a small portion of who this human
being is and with his decency I felt
they could take his hand and and play
this role in his film that somebody
needed to play or they couldn't make
them move
I think most of the characters have this
moral gray area that makes it really
true because it's tragedy and there's no
right now there's just no right answer
in this circumstance unfortunately so
that opens a lot of doors to just say
okay why is this guy like he is how did
he end up like this and you just really
start to figure it out more about what
happens before the film so in all those
silent moments you at least have a full
human being thinking there and the
makeup with a face I mean you were beat
to a pulp no that was real that was yeah
we've been deep deepening it's worth it
once you see yourself because it puts
you somewhere and it's worth it for the
audience but you know this is a very
private character and have people
touching your face all day it's actually
really hard for me you know before doing
a scene you sort of want to go and the
characters really far back into himself
somewhere and so to be constantly
touched you know I thought I don't think
he liked to be touched either so that
was actually challenging you know
there's a scene where I'm showing you
the pictures of the bloody children's
clothes and the scene was written as
Keller throwing me up against the wall
and strangling me and saying this is
your fault you did this in a really
violent way and on the day of that scene
and by the way we're shooting this
actually very quickly I mean we had an
ample amount of time in a way mostly
waiting for overcast weather in Atlanta
but but we really didn't have a lot of
time to clean certain spots and in the
police station we didn't and I remember
Hugh coming up and saying I just don't
feel right about doing this he's so
physical with with Paul's character and
he's going to be I don't even think they
had not even shot that stuff yet but he
said I really think it's much more
cutting if he just sat there and said to
him this is your fault you know you
wasted time and what ensued was Denis
saying I love that idea and in my
opinion like that some
the best acting I've ever witnessed in
front of me and some of the most
vulnerable acting I've ever seen from an
actor and the stuff that he does in that
scene and and I think what happens when
you have a director who is able to sort
of just steer the ship in the correct
way see that the moment exists and where
it exists and how it how it really can
be two examples of the ways in which
that script was taken away because of
the conversations and there was another
moment I think you will remember that I
couldn't I couldn't get my mind around
this ice bag over Holly's hand and it
didn't I didn't what it like she's
playing a trick with the guy I couldn't
what she heard her hand I wasn't I
wasn't really understanding it and and
then when I did begin to understand it I
just felt it would never work I felt it
would never work because I'd spent so
much brain time on it you know good old
actor thinking and Danny was also very
deft at getting us where we needed to be
when in fact there it was right on the
page in front of us only work with the
director that's in love with you
and that you're in love with because
that's the only way you'll trust him or
her or they will trust you everyone
should work with the director with a
French accent but there were more boobs
in the movie but I will say this is that
I know that acting is not rocket science
but it is an art form and I think you
know when you just personally you're
going from job to job and jump to job
you get on the set and you just want to
hit the result that's it and somewhere
along the line you forget the process
the creative process the getting there
the discovery the leaving yourself alone
the the thinking that you know exactly
what it is and then once you leave
yourself alone you're surprised and it
takes you in another direction but you
trust the director enough
to just fly with it it's such a
beautiful thing to remember what it is
that we do and for people to see the
results of what we do which is something
I think that was quite spectacular we'll
see tomorrow when we looked at the box
office